die kernfusion wurde auf einen schlag
all unsere energieprobleme lösen sie
produziert keine abgase braucht nur
wenig rohstoffe und produziert weniger
und auch weniger gefährlichen
radioaktiven abfalls als die
kernspaltung
jetzt hat die alpha energy eine halbe
milliarde dollar für die
weiterentwicklung ihres reaktors
eingesammelt dabei sind große und
seriöse investoren vertrauen in die
firma hat sie also einen oder sogar den
weg gefunden die kernfusion endlich
realität werden zu lassen
jetzt dixon herzlich willkommen
seit jahrzehnten doktor muss man ja
schon fast sagen die wissenschaft an der
kampf wo wir uns technik herum und dabei
wurden immer noch keine ergebnisse
geliefert also keine funktionierende
funktion zu schwierig scheint es zu sein
das heiße plasma der fusion zu
kontrollieren bei dem weg der
eingeschlagen wurde soll ein
ringförmiges plasma durch riesige
elektromagneten in einen sogenannten
pokermarkt in form gehalten werden es
darf nämlich nicht berühren denn in dem
plasma heißen bedingungen wie auf der
sonne und das sind temperaturen von
achtung 100 millionen grad die energie
wird dabei wie auf der sonne durch
wasserstoff atome gewonnen
die zu helium verschmelzen mit einem
kilogramm wasserstoff erzeugt man so mit
der kernfusion so viel energie wie mit
11.000 tonnen steinkohle im
französischen cannes das wird gerade der
forschungsreaktor iter gebaut der bau
dauert dabei immer länger und wird immer
teurer moment liegt das budget bei 16
milliarden dollar steigt aber voraus
wirklich nochmal um fünf milliarden
es ist nach der internationalen
raumstation das größte und teuerste
wissenschaftsprojekt der menschheit mit
neun jahren verspätung soll der
forschungsreaktor 2025 in betrieb gehen
nun erst 2035 soll er richtig
funktionieren und energie liefern das
wäre ein riesiger schritt jetzt scheint
aber eine kleine amerikanische sommer im
rennen um die kernfusion aufzuhalten
freistaates geschafft ein pflaster zu
erzeugen und ist für 11 5 millisekunden
also etwas mehr als eine zehntelsekunde
stabil zu halten was macht dich ist die
forscher arbeiten allerdings nach einem
komplett anderen prinzip als die
restlichen forschungsreaktoren dort wird
ein plasma in einem zuckermarkt
genannten ring erfolg bei treffer werden
zwei platten an zwei enden einer röhre
erzeugt und dann mit 900.000 kilometer
pro stunde aufeinander geschossen er
tier ist das was man dann so heißt dass
die fusion in gang kommt bei dem
verfahren entsteht das heiße plasma wohl
deutlich und aufwendiger denn mit der
investition von lediglich eine halbe
milliarde dollar will die firma schon
bis spätestens 2030 aber eher 2027 einen
funktionierenden prototypen gebaut haben
ob die amerikaner aufholen werden
immerhin wir haben hier entwicklung
darüber berichtet in der deutschen kerns
forschungsanlage wendelstein 7-x in
greifswald in mecklenburg-vorpommern
wurde ein plasma von 50 millisekunden
stabil gehalten also eine halbe sekunde
das ist der wahnsinn aber eben noch weit
entfernt von der kernfusion ich bin
extrem gespannt wie es weiter geht hier
auf pixum erfahrt ihr natürlich mehr
über die weiterentwicklung bei der
kernfusion wenn er nichts verpassen
wollt also kein video daumen drücken am
besten hier genau ein abo aufs auge
und wen auf die glocke natürlich nicht
vergessen
und hier geht es zum video über
wendelstein 7-x also drauf klicken wenn
er nicht dumm sterben wollte ja das
wollte ich noch sagen
bis dann